tradition of trust is that you yourself
have previously run every cell in that
notebook when that happens we keep track
of that we actually sign the notebook
and include that signature in the
notebook and we're able to compare that
and verify at a later time that you are
the one that ran all the cells in the
notebook and in that situation it's
deemed to be trusted we will run all
that output when you load the notebook
you can trust the notebook the other way
of trusting a notebook we have a
command-line interface I don't have time
to go into that there's a link here that
has a longer description of our security
system but it's important to understand
these things and how they relate to rich
output rich output also integrates with
in be zero so we haven't really
mentioned and be viewers NBD viewer is a
website that allows you to render
notebooks without having to install
ipython so for example if you post your
notebooks on github or any public
website you can enter the URL get
username username and repo just ID in
this field and that will allow you that
will give the user an immediate
rendering of that notebook as static
HTML so there's some examples here 11
fantastic example is cam Davidson pylons
book on bayesian methods and it is an
entire book that is the content is just
ipython notebooks on github rendered on
mb viewer so how does this relate to
rich output let's go back here exercise
if you have rich output in a notebook
that rich output makes it makes its way
over to MV viewer and is preserved and
if one that gets rendered on NB viewer
all that rich output will be run so for
example if you have a d3 visualization
and that d3 visualization use HTML
output and JavaScript output when you
run that on and be viewer it should work
now there there's a few small details to
that we've as if I Python 2 we've really
tried to iron out all those details so
you may run into things some things but
there's a lot of things that these days
are just working one fantastic example
that uses this is MP ld3 MPL d3 is a d3
based rendering engine for matplotlib of
plots and visualizations and so here is
an MP ld3 example and here there
embedding the env viewer page in the MPL
d3 documentation but when you scroll
down here maybe here we go you can see
that the map lib plot can be browsed
around its interactive and so MPL d3
generate HTML and JavaScript output that
works on NB viewer so your your objects
can do things like that as well and it
should just work all right so let's have
you do explore these this rich output
yourself so what I want you to do is try
using the display the basic display
classes in ipython in a notebook and
some some things that you can try one
find an image on the internet and
display in the notebook using the image
cloud
you can either save the image locally or
load it by its URL next try using the
HTML class and or the double % h 2 m @ l
magic to display a snippet of HTML if
you don't know HTML just Google for
simple HTML snippet and you know it can
be extremely simple if you know
JavaScript or if you can find a little
JavaScript snippet try that even just a
simple alert statement in JavaScript and
then try displaying these objects both
by returning them from an expression and
also by passing them to display and what
I will do here is again I'll show you
what the imports for these look like and
then I should note that the double
percent HTML double percent JavaScript
cell magics don't need to be important
those are always available when you
start up the ipython notebook with the
Python colonel
they will will give you let's see how it
maybe give you five minutes or so to
play around with this then we can come
around Thomas and then if you can
there's some other questions what did
you grab our ipython indep three ball
okay that's good could we made changes
right before the top so if you phoned
ipython in-depth looks then click on the
index interactive widgets what if you go
to rich output what will I guess I was
that that raise your hand if you have a
question
hard for me to get over there did you
get it figured out because so that so
there's two thirds this is a very subtle
question the colonel where python code
is running runs as your user it has
access to do anything your user would
have access to do the notebook web
application well it is running as your
user but the it is found that over that
directory of below and the reason we
didn't do that oh yes nothing under all
those directories any file on those
directories can be accessed with a
simple HTML get to the web application
so we said well we don't I don't want
your SD password to be available this is
through an agent again sure you can run
code again and so it's not you know
again yeah I mean it it's not it doesn't
solve the problem you know it's not know
it and we I mean the philosophy is we
want you to be able to do anything you
can do as your normal user code right
that's think of it as equivalent to a
terminal session it has the same
permissions yeah there's a couple ways
of doing it one if you just wanna run
python script you can do priscilla colon
space the name of the script to New then
I will run the code in the interactive
namespace if you want to inject a script
into a cell which you can then edit
remix percent load by Matthew the
directory and no I wanted the browser
Council Oh
can sit on linux and windows its control
shift I exact there it's not stuff when
did you are reporting okay so you did
that looks like an arrow swooshing let's
meet email format not this is just like
do did you be named it okay there you go
I don't know what the working directory
that's cool so we just
so I had a fantastic question that I
gotta go over a little bit while you
work on that it'll cover a few other
unrelated things related to python one
is the double percent right file magic
let's say you're in the notebook and you
want to write a small file without
opening a text editor right double
percent right file the name of the file
and then the contents of the file when
you run that exclamation runs a command
in the shell and so I can cap the file
if I want to inject that file into the
contents of a cell in the notebook it's
percent load food pipe so that has
injected the file into the following
cell if I want to just run that code but
not display it in the cell it's percent
run free dot pie and if I do print a I
see the available variable is there
you
yeah sure screen scroll up on this one
yeah there we go sorry happy hour people
don't do you think I should move on
there's some really weird problems with
images in the past I don't know if it's
something for the last minute what what
was it like an underscore person vanish
it says SVG in that's bizarre but means
working um
there's a lot of people that are skipped
ahead that's fine there's a lot of
people so I would say yes oh how are you
doing we're doing good this is still the
first clock yes hey so we're at least 12
hours so two other shortcuts that we
would only cover in an introductory
ipython talk one is that LS just works
and then the other is that CD works so
within a notebook and those work on any
platform so it's very convenient to
navigate the file system I should note
that the CD in this context is affecting
the current working directory of the
colonel not of the notebook user
interface dashboard and so those two
things are decoupled it would still work
if its windows yeah we translate it too
dear yes some people use ipython
terminal as their windows shell because
of that right it has tab completion it
has a lot of the nice things exactly
alright so
another exercise here and actually I
think I'll just go ahead and work
through this exercise in front of you so
just to show you how you can embed
content from other sites so here's let's
say I'm really into music and I don't
know we just need to make a business I
don't want to commercial that's no
let's say I like that and I want to
embed it I can click on share in bed I
can pick my player and then I copy the
HTML go back here throw that in want to
run it I've got an embedded soundcloud
player in the notebook and the point
here is that there's no magic it's just
the web right I mean things just wah
it's built on the standards that the web
fuses so another exercise that you could
do to search that probe and explore
sharing notebooks is if you've generated
a notebook now that have some rich
output try sharing it as a gist on
github and then pacing that gist number
into the env viewer page and viewing
that notebook and verifying that the
rich output actually indeed works on NB
viewer that's a another common usage
case that a lot of us are using to share
content with others
so I actually want to take a quick poll
we understand that it's really a
challenge to do a tutorial like this for
a wide range of users how many people
here feel like we're going to slow raise
your bald raise your hand we can go much
faster believe me okay so we've got some
going too slow how many people like feel
like we're going too fast okay all right
and that means that most of you think
we're going about right hopefully but if
you you know if we are going to start to
move a lot faster the material becomes a
lot more difficult please holler if
we're going too fast or too slow it we
understand that that's a challenge yes
so the question is how do you load d3 on
the page and use it in another tag so
the the example that I have in the rich
output notebook shows one way of doing
that as of I think it was about three
months ago d3 added some additional code
that changes how it's loaded depending
on whether or not require a s is found
on the page and one thing that you
should know is required is is loaded in
the notebook so that new logic and d3 is
triggered and when d3 finds that require
a s is on the page I think the way it
works is it actually prevents the global
d3 name from being populated it assumes
that it's going to be handled through
requires dependency tracking and so
there is a little bit of trickery and
subtle subtle issues to be aware of
their the simplest way what one you can
do like like we did in that example
another way is to actually use require
configure require to tell it where the
d3 CDN is
and then use an actual call to require
and put your code that uses d3 inside
that so there is a little bit of
subtlety there and it takes a little bit
to learn that unfortunately the web is
complicated it's never simple all right
yes another question is your question
what's the best way to debug JavaScript
one I mean we're writing JavaScript code
we almost always have the you know
chrome developer tools open looking at
the console doing console dot log it it
can be a little bit subtle when the
JavaScript your writing is coming from
Python code and that experience is still
not wonderful to be honest it should
display the air for you so like you'll
see the air in the notebook but then to
get to get a detail you know the debug
it in full and you have to open up the
console of the browser all right so
let's move on so at this point everyone
knows about the ipython built-in display
objects to built-in display function and
so this allows you to get a lot of
programmatically generated content into
your notebooks but what if you have your
own Python object and maybe it's a
Python object that is has a very complex
API and a very complex representation
and you would like to create a custom
JavaScript and HTML representation this
youth in the notebook how would you do
that and that is the next phase in the
tutorial and that is in the custom
display logic notebook so this display
system that we have built extends
pythons built-in notion of
representations and it does so actually
in a way that is really
inspired by how Python itself works in
Python it looks at the double underscore
wrapper double underscore method one way
of getting your own teaching your own
objects how to generate these rich
representations is by special methods
and so what we'll go over the naming of
these special methods how they work
another situation though is that
sometimes you're going to encounter an
object that you're not writing that
you're not defining so it's difficult
for you to write define a method on the
class and it's also really not
convenient for you to subclass to add a
method a perfect example of this would
be a numpy ndarray right it's already
it's an already existing object sub
classic that is going to be a complete
pain but maybe in some context you would
like to add a rich representation for
numpy arrays and so you can also do that
as well let's start by importing some of
the display functions and some of these
examples will need matplotlib we're not
really spending much time talking about
matplotlib and plotting in this context
I guess although mentioned now is that
these three lines right here especially
moving forward or the canonical way of
importing matplotlib and enabling it in
the notebook previously there was two
other ways one you could specify dash
dash pylab equals in line when you start
the notebook that's deprecated as of
Toronto and is going away completely as
if 30 which is coming out later this
year the purse double percent pylab in
line magic call in the notebook still
works but we're strongly steering people
away from that as it imports a lot of
things into your global namespace and
honestly leads to more problems than
it's worth for most users so there's
that so how do these discuss yes
so you can switch between the inline
back end and one of the GUI back ends
like the Cutie back end in the notebook
so if i were to later run % matplotlib
cutie it would switch to that other back
end what you can't do is switch between
two different GUI backends so you
couldn't switch between WX and QT know
yeah there's no simple user interface
like you click on a plot in the notebook
and have it pop out a cutie window that
that does not exist special display
methods so here are the special display
methods the naming of them so underscore
repper underscore the name of the the
data type and then a trailing underscore
and the Ripper HTML method needs to
return a string of HTML HTML
representation as a string the JPEG and
PNG returned the binary image data j sv
g is the SVG data as a string and then
la tech is the law text string
surrounded by the dollar signs right and
so the the AP is for these special
methods are really really simple and if
your object simply declares one of these
special methods if you return that
object in an expression or pass it to
display we will compute we will call
that method compute that representation
bring it back to the notebook and
display it so let's look at how this
works in practice so here's a Gaussian
object and the Gaussian object we can
pass a mean and a standard deviation and
then we're actually going to sample from
AG out that Gaussian distribution in
this case a thousand points and then we
have two special display methods the
first is repartee and repartee and G
it's going to store the PNG
in this semi-private attribute if we
haven't computed it before we call self
dot figure data cell figured out it's
where the actual PNG data is generated
using matplotlib in this case we're
simply going to build a histogram of
that data and notice in this case we're
going to close the fit the matplotlib
figure and we are going to return the
raw data that's returned by matplotlib
sprint figure function right so we're
actually computing the binary image data
and this special method and repartee ng
will return that data rep or la tech
again it just builds a lot text ring
here with the dollar signs on either
side as a Python string so let's run
this and then create an instance so here
it's going to have a mean of two
standard deviation of one and when we
run this notice and we're returning it
from an expression it detects all of
those representations it computes them
bring brings it back to the notebook and
notice in this case the notebook
considers la tech to be a richer
representation it will be the default
representation for this object even
though the P&G data was computed and so
if you were to use this notebooks in
different contexts where PNG was better
it would be able to use that data notice
that if I pass that same object to the
display function it uses the same
representation and compute all of them
if I pass that same object to display
PNG it only computes the PNG
representation and this is a really
important subtle difference between
display and the display underscore foo
functions display computes all
representations and lets the notebook
user interface decide which to use the
display underscore foo methods only
compute that particular representation
right we can also create another
Gaussian here so here is x2
you and then this is an example where we
can call display one of the display
functions multiple times in a cell and
we can actually see the to see the two
distributions that compare the gaussians
yes the built book user interface has a
hard-coded display priority list and we
sort of have a background thread
thinking about ways in which we could
allow that to be customized or basically
you know what how to make it easy for a
user in the notebook user interface to
switch representations yeah it's a
simple linear priority of display
formats yes so the question is what's
the advantage of display computing all
representations if the notebook is only
two going to display one of them a
perfect example of this would be let's
say you're working interactively and you
have a map plot lib plot in the notebook
the representation that makes sense
there is probably going to be a PNG
figure possibly SVG although the SVG
matplotlib rendering is not by default
enabled in the past there's been some
instabilities with it so that's why P&G
is a default but let's say you write a
notebook and then you want to generate a
PDF high quality quality vector-based
PDF that you're going to share with a
bunch of people and be convert which is
I pythons tool for converting notebooks
is aware of those representations and if
for example when you generate at that
map cutlet plot you had also enabled PDF
formatting for that figure object the
PDF data will be embedded in the
notebook when you convert it to logic
and PDF the figure that will appear in
your fine
PDF will be the vector on PDF graphic
not the PNG that that's a sort of a
classic example of creating a notebook
that's going to be used in multiple
context and the the Python code that
generates those representations has
absolutely no way to guess ahead of time
what those end usage cases will be so
that that's why we we compute all
representations in practice most Python
objects have very few representations
for example matplotlib plots have I
think by default two representations a
simple text string and then the PNG
representation what panda's data frames
have an HTML and a textual although
actually I think pandas has internal
switching where they can enable and
disable particular representations sort
of ahead of time before it hits display
but but so far we haven't run into many
situations where it's problematic to
compute all those representations but if
you did have an object where that was a
problem the way I would handle it would
be by defining some internal API in that
object that controls whether or not a
given representation is computed these
special methods if they return none that
representations ignored you could build
internal logic all right
pi another important usage case is when
there's an existing object that you
would like to add display logic to but
you're not going to subclass that object
and so in this example we're going to
take the numpy polynomial object which
is here here's a function poly to la
tech that takes that polynomial and
build a nice formatted la tech
representation and we can see what that
looks like so here's the la tech and we
would like that la tech representation
to be automatically generated and
display in the notebook any time it's
used with the display function and so
one way we could do that would be to
wrap it in one of these this built-in
display class la tech that works fine
but again it you have to add additional
logic there and I python has a formatter
API this format API allows you to
associate a Python function on one hand
that Python function knows how to
compute a given representation with a
type or class an existing type or class
and so the API for getting to the these
for matters you type get ipython and
then this code here displays the list of
for matters that are available so under
the IP object there's display format or
dot for matters for matters is a
dictionary the keys net dictionary or
the mime types listed on the left the
values in that dictionary are the actual
form for matter objects that handle the
formatting for that type so let's
actually get the la tech for matter so
here it's the high Python object display
for matter dot for matters not text / la
tech and then there's two methods that
you can use to register your display
function one is for type the idea here
see you pass an actual class and then a
function or for type by name where you
can give it the a module as a string and
a the name of a class as
and a function and so in this case we're
going to use for type by name so we're
going to say the module is numpy
polynomial polynomial the class is
polynomial with a capital P and here's
our display function we register it and
then when we returned that it
automatically computes the low-tech
representation here another polynomial
right and so it's possible to declare
custom display logic both using these
special methods and these standalone
display functions and yeah one other
thing that I'm just going to mention
very briefly because we want to make
sure that we have time to go into a good
depth on the widgets is there are times
when you want to display something and
have a lot more control over how that
happens for example maybe you want to
simultaneously display both HTML and
JavaScript right and to do that we have
another display method called i
underscore ipython underscore display
underscore and that is as one of our
developers said it's a way for you to
tell I python back off ipython I can
display this myself and if this method
exists we'll call it and then we'll just
do whatever you say and so here's an
example of a flop plot object that makes
a plot using the flat JavaScript
plotting library and inside its display
method it calls display HTML to put HTML
on the page and display JavaScript to
put JavaScript on the page right and so
when we run that we can then create an
ump simple numpy data set and we can get
a plot using flaw wait so that that's
something to be aware of so I think I
just want to point out we have a
notebook that has exercises on custom
display logic we're going to skip that
so we have time to go into the
interactive
widgets and I think it's a great time
we're about halfway through our time
we're going to take a few minute break
get up get some coffee there's some food
in the hallway restrooms or out these
doors and this way along the scop what
does the Cubs scop hopscotch that's on
the floor you'll see it so what we'll be
back in a few minutes